pas avant les séries les séries c'est
pour l'apa de la musique a alors les
cherry on va démarrer pour se mettre en
confiance tous
on va démarrer par maxime dénis vas-y
maxime
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
94 64 ans 4,63 c'est pas mal à les
champions à laquelle ils veulent me
paraissent pas oui
malik a bola 680 nous sommes allés
georges st pierre et miquelon
[Rires]
non d'après transfert de marc sangnier
et l'autre est l'hôte à nos spectacles
en mission g après une seule saison avec
les mains jean-michel ans
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
voilà où la walker homélie pas bracha
pas l'aï même pas mal mais et afin que
le prénom moi j'ai fait mais la droite
et danois jesper la technique maxime
gainey je vous à quoi vous inspirez
bonne foi au public à les champions au
nom salle opus mans ça monte doucement à
saint laurent wauquiez
[Applaudissements]
on a vu pire c'est un agent de sécurité
c'est comme chez toi le truc qui joue
c'est vrai c'est vrai que sans lui est
situé chargé de la sécurité
si j'étais au dessus c'était pas
possible non mais la région c'est vrai
c'est comme si tu demandes de baguette
et le boulot j'étais sans voix
attention georges st pierre jonette
qu'est ce que tu veux nous faire d'avoir
tu vas nous faire un petit coucou très
costaude avec d'avoir un coup de coude
déjà combattu fait juste au coup de
coude non c'est nous bat avec l'oeil fc
chooz jacques monsieur claude c'est pas
ton malin comme l'a dit jean lacombe
r'bat mokhtaria fait combien soit 44 843
abri je suis me demande toujours à quoi
ont servi dans cette séquence
tu vas à bord et pourquoi toi mon frère
tu vas tu
[Applaudissements]
zéro je veux pas te laisser repartir
comme ça au québec où les wampas et ils
vont se déplacer fais pas tu arrives à
lannion pas vous faut allez on y va
ok je vais pouvoir calme toi est papa de
blessés bon centre à fabrice c'est mieux
c'est un ami quand même mis son nom mais
qu il ya une tête incroyable c'est le
mec qui m'ennuie le plus beau jour de sa
vie
mais ça je suis fan de change
[Applaudissements]